qui envoie les fautes et les mecs non ça
rigolait qui envoie les envoie les
photos et envoie des photos et je me
souvins non c'est moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci à toi
mais à
dans l'instant kad merad sera avec nous
les cherry et on aura un quart d'heure
son fils s'ils ont mis la legal danané à
l'ère numérique et kad merad
c'est pas possible cette banque ils ont
pas dû 4 il croit que c'est crade
elmaleh il refaire une dernière fois
mignon sur la tête de ma mère si vous
mettez de la photo de gad elmaleh je
viens origines et vous venez ça je vais
voir car on voit s'achever ce quinté
dans un instant on va recevoir 4 merad
et on voit les fautes et les mecs non ça
rigolait tient au palais qui envoie les
photos et on voit les photos c'est chez
moi je veux un nom c'est moi et avec
tout mon cas
regardez ce sera mon body
m avec coups 4-4 il est très heureux de
te voir vraiment à l'époque de comédie
vous pensez que c'est résoudre à finir
est plutôt animateurs ou vendeurs de rue
lapierre à raisonner moment franchement
très honnêtement je suis épaté par le
parcours de 2 cyrille à se connaître
franchement non mais oh mais on peut
dire aussi des choses des voix des vrais
de vrais trucs entre eux c'est quelqu'un
qui était qui n'était pas tout à fait
traîner dans l'est dans les bureaux et
des tops à la contacter stagiaires il
tenait avec nous puis un jour il devient
toi tu vas jouer à la course et
pakistanais doit pas redondant pamela
rose très peu à la hâte en fait des
mercury pakistanais donc ça m'arrive à
moi aussi c'est peut-être pas une bonne
nouvelle pour tourner mais c'est grâce à
eux
aujourd'hui que j'ai fait de la télé je
le dis à chaque fois franchement mon 4
ta maman parce qu'il venait et après il
venait me chercher tous les soirs à un
moment il ya dominique farrugia il fait
il faut le laisser un petit peu à partir
de 16 heures j'étais en costume siffler
un très bon vendeur de canapés en cuir
c'est voilà qui est dingue je pensais
cyril hanouna mais je dis bon je dis ce
que je pense je dis voilà je trouve que
c'est un c'est une réussite ses amis qui
me fait rire c'est qu'à cannes à mon
talent qu'est caméra c'est une quotidien
comme ça c'est difficile on faisait ça
aussi donc le français y descend il m'a
pas payé on se parle on s'attaque jamais
je reçois même pas textos quand même pas
tous numéros ces web alors attends je
vais te le donner
[Musique]